you know we're constantly told these
days to follow
the science believe in science the
science will guide us the science will
save us
all hail science our redeemer this is a
message we have heard
especially during the covet lockdowns
which have been justified on the basis
of
science and by on the basis of science i
mean on the basis of the word itself
this is usually how science is wielded
in arguments these days in order to
prove that science is on one
side one need only shout the words
science and
research and evidence while providing
actual examples of none of them
you know like do your research haven't
you ever heard of science you dummy
look at the evidence and that's all
that's the whole argument
loud and confident assertion in the
place of persuasion which pretty much
sums up
all debate on the internet these days
and much of what you get from the left
in this country
the left is especially fond of talking
about science though not necessarily as
fond of the thing itself
yesterday on the show just as an example
i played a strange little skit
from the demented mayor of chicago uh uh
celebrating science ostensibly and it's
really not necessary that i play it
again but i'm going to anyway just to
torture you and so here it is
[Music]
thank god science is back baby
and the earth is round
not flat washing your hands
does work social distancing
does matter and wearing a face covering
does help protect all of us
i do love science
yes you're welcome for that don't take
me off or i might keep playing that
that will be my punishment for the
audience any time it misbehaves
the lori lightfoot videos will continue
until morale improves
but in any case um you see there's
science science is back
and of course governor cuomo in new york
is a big fan of talking about science he
said that
following science is the reason why he's
decided to
as we discussed yesterday take the
absurdly unconstitutional step of
telling people
how many family members they're allowed
to have in their own homes what this has
to do with science and
how science it all vindicates this move
is not explained
it's never explained and it's
interesting that from the follow
science and believe in science crowd you
also get this
abigail schreier wrote a book called
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters
and it's about as the title suggests
left-wing gender ideology and how it's
being imposed on our children
here's a description of the book on
amazon i think it's important to
understand
what the book is about so that the
madness of what we're going to discuss
next is perfectly clear so the
description says until just a few years
ago gender dysphoria severe discomfort
in one's biological sex was vanishingly
rare it was typically found in less than
.01 percent of the population
emerged in early childhood and afflicted
males almost exclusively but today whole
groups of female
friends in colleges high schools and
even middle schools across the country
are coming out as transgender
these are girls who had never
experienced any discomfort in their
biological sex
until they heard a coming out story from
a speaker at a school assembly or
discovered the internet community of
trans influencers
unsuspecting parents are awakening to
find their daughter's enthrall to hip
trans youtube stars and gender affirming
educators and therapists
who push life-changing interventions on
young girls including medically
unnecessary double mastectomies
and puberty blockers that can cause
permanent infertility abigail schreier a
writer for the wall street journal
has dug deep into the trans epidemic
talking to the girls their agonized
parents and the counselors and doctors
who enable
gender transitions as well as to
detransitioners young women who bitterly
regret what they've done to themselves
coming out as transgender immediately
boosts these girls social status driver
fines
but once they take the first steps of
transition it's not easy to walk back
she offers urgently needed advice about
how parents can protect their daughters
okay sounds like a great book an
important book i'd heard of the book
before it hadn't read it
i've now ordered a copy of it myself but
the more important point
is that it's a book talking about a very
real phenomenon
and calling attention to a problem that
many people would prefer to ignore
it's also a book it would seem grounded
in science that is grounded in the
recognition of
the reality of biological sex and child
psychology
it is through the recognition of these
two realities and through understanding
them that a person can see that the
transgender craze among children
is a problem it's a crisis in fact
but the pro-science people um don't like
this kind of science
so the woke squad has been hounding
schreier and trying to get her shut down
and censored
and going after anyone who sells the
books yesterday a couple of
trans activists and it was just a couple
from what i could tell
tweeted at target complaining that the
forbidden text was on sale in their
stores
target within hours very quickly
responded and pulled the book from their
shelves
all it took was a few trans activists
just shouting the word transphobia
and targets a multi-billion dollar
company
caved in like a quaking sinkhole
and apologized and said they'd remove it
just like that
it must be nice to wield that kind of
cultural power
i mean trans people say they're
oppressed by our society and yet
just one or two of them can go to target
and say i don't much care for this
product you're selling
and the whole company will fall to its
knees beg for forgiveness
remove whatever item was distressing
them do you think i could get that
response
do you think i as the dreaded privileged
cisgender white man
could go to target and say hey target
get rid of this book here
i don't like it and they would actually
say yes sir as you wish
i doubt it now once i'm fascist dictator
of the hemisphere you could be damn sure
they'll listen but for now not so much
because i'm not so lucky as to be
oppressed in that way
in the way that so many groups in
america are quote oppressed
by the way as mentioned there's been a
lot of censorship around this book and
of course
uh this issue more broadly um this week
also gofundme shut down a fundraiser by
a group of parents
who are trying to raise money to put up
billboards that were supposed to combat
the manipulation and corruption of
children by the radical lgbt lgbt left
the billboard said puberty is not a
medical condition
and then there was a picture of
schreier's book and a message urging
people to read it
gofundme stopped the fundraiser citing
their rules against
hate speech and this is what you get
if you follow the science in the way
that the left wants you to
namely they want you to follow not the
science
but doctrine and they want you to follow
it all the way over a cliff
and into the abyss see the thing is
following science i mean actually
following signs if the phrase means
anything at all
must mean simply weighing all the
information available
analyzing it coolly and rationally and
making informed judgments
science after all is not some sort of
creature it's not some entity it's not
some mysterious
being that commands our allegiance
science is the study of the physical and
natural world
and following science means it means not
not blindly accepting whatever someone
tells you in the supposed name of
science
but rather approaching issues as
objectively as possible
and drawing conclusions based on an
honest analysis of the available
information
it'd probably be better to say instead
of follow the science
as if the science is some homogeneous
never-changing
thing which issues decrees like the
wizard in the wizard of oz
instead maybe we should say think
scientifically or maybe even better
putting the word science to the side we
might just tell people to be honest
to be rational be thoughtful that's
really what's needed in our society
but whether we're endeavoring to follow
the science think scientifically or
simply be honest and rational
none of that is possible if entire
categories of thought are forbidden
if volumes of research and evidence on a
given subject are thrown in the
incinerator
because they might offend the wrong
people if perfectly valid and
intelligent points of view are not
allowed to be expressed or are
are shouted down rather than listen to
and engaged with
i mean if you really want to follow the
science and you don't agree with
schreier or people like her
then present your arguments against her
make your case
say i disagree here's why
you'll have quite a hard row in front of
you if you want to make an argument
against
schreier's view that we shouldn't push
gender confusion on our children
but if that's your view defend it the
problem is that most of the people with
that view
the opposing viewers triers know they
can't defend it
they can't begin to make a coherent case
so they scream and shout and pout
and punish and censor of course all the
while
still extolling the virtues of quote
unquote
science well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content